does it make sense to you why python has
become the primary the dominant language
for the machine learning community so
packages like uh pytorch tensorflow
second learn and even like the lower
level stuff like numpy sci-fi pandas
command plot lib with the visualization
can you like does it make sense to you
why it uh
uh permeated the entire data science
machine learning AI community
well it's part of it is an effect that's
as simple as
we're all driving on the right side of
the road right
uh it's compatibility yeah it's it's in
and and and and part of it is uh
not not quite as as as fundamental as
driving on the right side of the road
which you have to do for for safety
reasons I mean you have to agree on
something every they could have picked
JavaScript or Pearl there was there was
a time in the early 2000s that it really
looked like Pearl was going to dominate
like biosciences
because DNA search was all based on
regular expressions and pearl has the
fastest and most comprehensive regular
expression engine still does
I spent quite a long time with pearl
that was another letting go
letting go of this kind of uh data
processing uh system yeah the reasons
why python
became the lingua Franca of scientific
code and and
the machine learning learning in
particular and data science
it really had a lot to do with
anything was better than C or C plus
plus
recently a guy who worked at Lawrence
Livermore National Laboratories in the
the sort of computing division
wrote me his his Memoirs and and he had
his his own view of how he helped
something he called computational
steering into existence
and this was the idea that you you take
libraries that in in his days were
written in Fortran that that solved
Universal mathematical problems
uh and those libraries still work but uh
the scientists that use the libraries
use them to solve continuously different
specific applications and answer
different questions
and so those four scientists
were
were required to to use say Fortran
because Fortran was the library the
language that the library was written in
and then the scientist would have to
write an application that sort of uses
the library to solve a particular
equation or set off
of answer a set of questions and the
safe same for C plus plus
because and there's there's
interoperability so the dusty decks are
written either in C plus plus or Fortran
uh
and so Paul DuBois was one of the people
who
I think in the mid 90s
saw that that you needed a higher level
language
for the scientists
to to sort of tie together the
fundamental mathematical algorithms of
linear algebra and and other stuff
and so
gradually some libraries started
appearing that did very fundamental
stuff with arrays of numbers in Python I
mean when I first created python I was
not expecting it to be used for arrays
of numbers much I thought that was like
an outdated data type
and everything was like objects and
strings and like python was good and
fast at string manipulation and objects
obviously but arrays of numbers were not
very efficient in the multi-dimensional
arrays didn't even exist in the language
at all
uh but there were people who realized
that python had extensibility
that was flexible enough that they could
write
third-party packages that did support
large arrays of numbers and operations
on them very efficiently
and somehow they got a foothold
through sort of different
parts of the scientific Community I I
remembered that the Hubble Space
Telescope people in Baltimore Were
Somehow big python fans in the late 90s
and at various points
small improvements were made and more
people got in touch with using python to
derive these libraries
of interesting uh algorithms and like
once once you have a bunch of scientists
who are working on similar problems say
they're all working on stuff that that
come data that comes in from the Hubble
Space Telescope but they're looking at
different things some some are looking
at stars in this galaxy other are
looking at galaxies the math is
completely different but the the
underlying
libraries are still the same
and so they Exchange
code they say well I wrote this Python
program or I wrote a python library to
solve this class of problems
and the other guys either say oh I can
use let Library 2 or if you make a few
changes I can use that Library too
why why start from scratch in Pearl or
JavaScript
where there's not that infrastructure
for arrays of numbers yet whereas in
Python you have it and so more and more
scientists at different places doing
different
different work
discovered Python and then then people
who had an idea for an important new
fundamental Library decided oh python is
is actually already known to our users
so
let's use python as the user interface I
think that's how tensor I imagine at
least that's how tensorflow ended up
with python as the user interflow
interface right but with tensorflow
there's a deeper history of what the
community is it's not just like what
packages it needs it's like what the
community leans on for programming
language because tensorflow
uh had a prior library that was internal
to Google but there was also competing
machine learning Frameworks like thiano
Cafe they were in Python there was some
Scala
um some other languages but python was
really dominating it
and it's interesting because
um there's other languages from the
engineering space like Matlab
that a lot of people used but different
design choices by the company by the
core developers led to it not spreading
and one of the choices of Matlab
uh by math works is to not make it open
source right or yeah not you know having
people pay it was a very expensive
product and so uh universities
especially disliked it because it was a
price per seat I I remember hearing
yeah but I think that's not why it
failed or it failed to spread I think
the universities didn't like it but they
would still pay for it
the thing is it didn't feed into that
GitHub open source uh packages culture
so like and that's somehow a
precondition for um for viral spreading
the hacker culture like the tinkerer
culture uh with python it feels like you
can build a package from scratch or
solve a particular problem and get
excited about sharing that package with
others and that creates an excitement
about a language I tend to like Python's
approach to open source in particular
because it's sort of
it's almost egalitarian
uh there's there's little hierarchy
there's there's obviously some because
the like you only need to decide whether
you drive on the left or the right side
of the road sometimes
but there is a lot of access for people
with little power you don't have to work
for a big tech company to make a
difference in the python world
uh we have affordable events that really
care about community and support people
and sort of the community is is
is like a big deal at our conferences
and in in the BSF when the psf funds
events it's always about
growing the community the psf funds very
little development
they that they do some but most of the
develop most of the money that the psf
forks out
uh is to community
fostering things